why do i focus on gratitude first thing
in the morning well i have my vision
board and then my goals everything that
i want but i also have a gratitude board
the things that i'm most grateful for in
my life and if you want to feel instant
gratitude just count all the things in
your life that you have that money can't
buy
gratitude is also good for your brain
there was a cover story on the cover of
time magazine on these super nuns who
are living 80 90
and above and i want to find how where's
their longevity coming from half of it
had to do with their gratitude emotional
faith the other half had to do with
there were lifelong learners so those
two things combined and very very
powerful
after that i'm drinking my tea i'm
writing in my journal because a lot of
geniuses write in journals right
leonardo da vinci einstein marie curie
all these journals and they want to do
these studies say are geniuses writing
in journals because they're geniuses or
is it the opposite it's because they're
writing in journals that they become
these incredible geniuses of their field
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside youtube
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn some of the
most productive morning routines to
start your day off right
enjoy
routine number two avoid distraction
with brendan burchard here's how most
people though unfortunately start their
day they wake up from bed and they reach
over they grab their phone and they pull
their phone to their face and then they
go
and they start scrolling
through and some people you can
literally hear them growing
it's like they just immediately start
the day their real morning routine is
starting their day in social media now
let's talk about why that is bad
scientifically so not my opinion not
like i'm the guy telling you stop doing
instagram i'm sharing with you some
results from the world's largest study
that's ever been done on high performers
high performers are basically the top 15
of the most successful group
in whatever their category is meaning
it's the most successful 15
of business owners or the most
successful yoga instructors or the most
successful videographers the most
successful whatever we've studied over 2
million data points from 190 countries
around the world to understand what do
high performers do what are their habits
what do they do what do they focus on
what's their mind like not just like how
do they show up but rather what are they
doing willfully and on purpose and one
thing they are not doing is starting
their day in social media almost none of
them but think about what that will is
it's like you wake up you grab the phone
uh you start scrolling through
psychologically what is that doing for
you
first social media is triggering in your
mind the comparison frame
you immediately start comparing oh look
at her abs oh look at his thing oh he's
got this look at their followers i don't
have that impact i wish i could be like
this i want to be like that you're
immediately comparing your life to other
people what else you're doing you're
scrolling and as you're scrolling
neurologically we know that as doing the
reason you like to scroll so much and
swipe so much and move so much through
that phone is because every time you do
it fires off in your brain something
called novelty and when we have
novelties something new to look at our
brain likes it and our brain says well
let's give them a little dopamine a
little vasopressin let's make them feel
good and so oh the more i do this the
more your brain goes distraction yay
look new things shiny same thing and
you're swiping through this and as you
are swiping through all of this
you are forgetting your life and your
day i mean imagine would you ever tell
like a middle school kid hey what i want
you to do a kid is wake up every morning
and immediately start thinking about how
the other kids in school are and start
comparing yourself to everybody
no one of us as adults would teach small
children to start their day comparing
themselves to other people
and yet that's what you're doing when
you pick up that phone
what you're doing is you are
neurologically training your brain
to be rewarded by comparison and
distraction because right think about
the anchor here wake up grab look scroll
and what is that doing it is training
your brain first thing in the morning
check out of your life and check into
other people's lives
every morning you are training your
brain to check into other people's lives
not
carefully and strategically and
intentionally think about yours
so what that means is if you're a person
who is checking your phone first thing
in the morning going through social
media
you by definition
by checking into other people's lives
comparison yourself to other people's
lives you are ultimately training your
brain neurologically
to live
other people's lives
to see life from the perspective of
other peoples versus your own vision
your own dream your own thoughts your
own strategy your own intention
you are training your brain to live
other people's lives
so that's the worst thing you can do
please be thoughtful about this and i
know i know when you're like but it's
hard brendan i just love to pick up the
phone i know i know because that's an
addiction
every time you do something if you have
to do it every day and it's something
that you do every day that is leading to
a negative result that's an addiction
and you must teach yourself to break
that you must not do that i had to
personally i literally do not have my
phone by my bedside
like when i had this i noticed i was
like gosh i check in
i've seen the results i've seen the
studies why am i doing this so i turn my
phone off i put it in the kitchen
counter charging and i'm in the bedroom
sleeping which is really important right
to keep you sane so i think it's just a
change the worst morning routine we can
have is to immediately be in the day in
comparison and distraction
second terrible routine that people love
to do is they gotta check in again check
in
email i gotta check my email i gotta
check my email i gotta check my text i
gotta check this but listen your texts
and your email
are nothing but convenient organizing
systems
of other people's agendas
think about that for a minute what shows
up in your inbox or in your texts what
shows up in your messages
other people's will for you
other people telling you what to do what
to think what they need from you what
the deadline is stress stress stress
stress stress
and most people are literally beginning
their day checking their text their
voice message and their inbox which is
all other people's agendas and needs
from you
so again you are starting your day in
other people's lives and needs routine
number three make your bed with lewis
house your mom probably told you growing
up as well as to make your bed and
there's a great book
by william h
mcraven that says
it's about making your bed and he is a
navy admiral that talks about
if you want to live a great life
make your bed and this is a massive
number one new york time best-selling
book this speech went viral online
and it's something that is so simple
but sometimes we think about we've got
to have some complicated morning routine
that
you know biohacking everything we can in
order to optimize our day and really
when we go back to the basics that's
when you start to transform your life
everything goes back to basics
so make your bed first thing there is
there's something that happens and i
started doing this years ago there's
something that happens
when you
decide to take pride
in your personal space
when you decide to say okay i slept here
i slept here for
uh you know six seven eight hours
and i want to make sure i have a clean
space when i come home at night
by doing that you set yourself up for
success you accomplish something first
thing in the morning you build momentum
and you create pride and confidence in
yourself because you did something for
you you did it for yourself so when you
come home at night you can say wow the
time and energy i spent early in the day
paid off for me tonight now i can go to
sleep in a restful space so something to
consider try this for a week make your
bed every morning
it's the last thing you want to do
because you want to get up you want to
go to the bathroom you want to brush
your teeth and you want to get on with
it but i'm telling you if you take those
2-3 minutes you come back at night
you'll be proud of
yourself for what your past self did to
help you in the future
good book by my man evan carmichael
built to serve if you want to learn
about your purpose and how to become a
better leader in the world i love this
he says this is the starting point for
everything
if you're confused about what to do next
if you're pressured by others to fit in
or live
their version of your life
if you feel held back because of people
judging you it's because you don't know
who you are and what you stand for
you got to figure out who you are and
what you want
and how you can serve other people
routine number four get up early with
robin sharma my whole life is really
about teaching people exceptionalism and
one of the real strategies for high
performance and leading without a title
is getting up early you might say
getting up early is not really relevant
to you and yet if i look at the best of
the best whether it's in business in
science in the arts in sports
these are people who have trained their
brains
to show up at discipline
and getting up early is not only an
incredible competitive advantage because
most of your competitors are asleep but
getting up early is a great gift to give
yourself you get more life uh ben
franklin said it really well he said
there'll be plenty of time to sleep when
you're dead
so getting up early and giving yourself
that 60 minute personal leadership hour
really you practice and you prepare just
like beckham practices to be world class
as a footballer or
hamilton lewis practices on the track to
be a world class car racer or mozart
practice to be a world-class
composer
you give yourself one hour from five to
six and you do your practice but here's
the thing i really want to focus on how
do you get up earlier
so a few quick hopefully very practical
ideas number one get super fit when you
are in world-class physical condition
you just need less sleep your metabolic
rate is higher you have a lot more
energy a lot more stamina a lot more
passion get super fit and you're just
going to need less sleep number two
every single week get a massage getting
a massage
is not a waste of time it's
not a cost it's an investment why
because it'll increase your circulation
it'll help you get by on a lot less
sleep it's something that every peak
performer should do every seven days
just to
allow yourself to play at your absolute
best number three your diet eat less
food you'll have more energy don't eat
after eight o'clock and
eat every four hours a little bit of
protein a little bit of carbs but the
real key is eat less food manage your
diet you will need less sleep another
idea
get up in the morning and take the time
to write in a journal in other words
dump the worries out of your mind onto a
crisp white piece of paper when you
worry you lose energy i call it
dissipation and the more things you
worry about
the less energy you will have and the
more sleep you'll need and the fifth
thing i'll say is learn to find ways to
love your job
lead without a title i have met
room cleaners whose
clean hotel rooms like picasso painted
so find ways in your current job
to be passionate about your job be the
absolute best in your job why because
few things create more energy than going
to work every day and feeling that your
work is meaningful feeling that you can
show leadership within your area of
responsibility feeling that your work is
a craft whether you flip hamburgers or
work in human resources but one of the
great secrets to passion is purpose in
your work get up early it'll be one of
the best moves you make routine number
five do what you can with mel robbins
so i wake up at 6 15 to this alarm clock
that simulates the sunrise then i pet my
dog then i always make my bed uh this is
a really important tip so the night
before you
are going to sleep lay out your exercise
clothes because when you see them in the
morning it acts like a trigger in your
mind to remind you of your promised
exercise and even though i get dressed i
don't feel like exercising here's
another pro tip
i
program my mind to be positive
all day and i practice gratitude while
brushing my teeth i brush with my
non-dominant hand which is the hand that
you normally don't write with so i brush
my teeth with my left hand because i'm a
righty and then as i am brushing my
teeth with my left hand i have to pay
attention
because it's not really a natural thing
to do and as i'm paying attention i have
my gratitude practice where i think
about what i'm grateful for i love it
when the spring flowers are coming up
we've turned our family room into a gym
and uh i have
tagged a bunch of the classes and
instructors that i love for you to check
out oh gotta go to the bathroom oh
there's chris
now let's get started with the class
braxton here we go oh forgot my water
bottle i have terrible add it is true
what do i put in my water bottle baraka
holly jacobs from sony pictures
television i love you for introducing me
to this
kind of hard to exercise when you have a
puppy
but makes you grateful
uh what do i eat for breakfast either a
smoothie or eggs from the chickens
across the street and i'm telling you
right now your morning routine is
everything so get up early and find time
for yourself so there you have it that's
my typical morning routine and
it never fails every morning that i
stick to my routine i have a
much more powerful day and the mornings
that i don't stick to the routine
suck honestly because i wake up behind
the ball when i get up when the alarm
rings i have made and kept a promise to
myself
when i make the bed i am
uh completing something before i leave
the bedroom and i also
whenever i walk back into the bedroom i
see something that has been accomplished
i don't see a mess that needs to be
completed
um by prioritizing my
physical and mental health
and getting some exercise in i not only
feel better mentally but i also release
chemicals in my brain that helps me
focus there is no doubt that having a
powerful morning routine is part of
every successful person's programs it is
something that you deserve it is
something that you should create for
yourself and it is something that will
improve your life refresh your routine
why is this important i'll tell you why
that's this is important because there
is so much science that talks about the
power of your morning routine and
there's also so much noise out there
about the morning routine and i don't
know about you but when i read all these
articles about the power of a morning
routine i'm typically reading them by
some male influencer who clearly doesn't
have children yet or some male ceo no no
offense to the dudes but all of the
articles out there tend to be written by
guys
that have
two and a half hours before work starts
to somehow drink mushroom tea and
meditate and go to yoga and exercise and
drink bulletproof coffee and sit in an
infrared sauna and i don't know what
planet these people live on but they
clearly don't have children or a job
they need to get to at eight o'clock in
the morning and not to make anyone wrong
i'm being realistic i'm being realistic
about the fact that you need a morning
routine but you need one that works for
you
and for where you are in your life in
this season you see i had a morning
routine that used to take me 30 to 40
minutes
last year when i had more time i've had
a morning routine that took an hour when
i had time and the ability to go for a
jog in the morning i'd incorporate that
in the morning routine do you realize
that my morning routine right now
has been responsible for helping me curb
my anxiety it's responsible for why i'm
so successful and i'm able to be
productive my morning routine 10 minutes
long that's it it's 10 minutes long
because that's what works for me in this
season of my life here's the thing about
morning routines i think morning routine
envy is a real thing
and
i do believe that a lot of people lie
about their morning routines
i think lying about your morning routine
is a real thing i think pretending you
have the perfect morning routine is a
real thing
um i'm
i'm about when i'm home i'm almost 80 in
my morning routine i get it done
because it's super simple right so i
mean i think i need a simple one yes
and when i'm traveling
i almost never get the whole thing done
because there's too many excuses so i
think the key to
having a morning routine and morning
routines are critical
because how you start your day
has a massive
proven impact on how your day turns out
there's one piece of research that i
think is really profound and this comes
from sean anchor i talked about this
yesterday but i'm going to tell you um
this too suzy
if you consume three minutes just three
minutes of negative news
of negative television
of negative emails maybe stressful
emails from work or stressful texts from
friends
you have more than a 50 percent chance
eight hours later to say you had a bad
day
and the reason why is because of what
consuming that kind of information does
to your mind
it literally sets your mind up to be on
the lookout for things going wrong and
so the reason why a morning routine is
is actually so important is because
number one
it determines what your priority for the
day is
and we also know based on research that
your mood in the morning
it impacts your productivity all day
long you must come up with a morning
routine
that you do
every single morning or at least more
mornings than not
that puts you in control of yourself and
in control of your day
this is what i do
and i cannot explain the power that i
get
from starting my day off and being
bigger than my excuses and being in
control
first and foremost
wake up on time when that alarm goes off
get your butt out of bed five four three
two one go
why is that important for persistence
the reason why is because the first
decision that you're making of the day
is to actually get up and get moving
that means you are
persistently
bigger than your excuses
you are persistently bigger than feeling
lazy
and you are persistently beating the
feelings that typically stop you
the second thing that i want you to do
before you look at your email
before you answer your phone before you
start surfing vox and vice and buzzfeed
and you know team stream and checking
out the sales on zappos and looking at
your facebook news feed before you pick
up the damn phone
please please please
figure out your two priorities for the
day these are the things that matter to
you whether it's saving money and and
making sure you're focused on that or
showing up at work and being a
contributor or whether it's changing how
you treat your spouse or your kids or
the person that you're with or heck
getting to the gym because you said you
would whatever it is that your two
priorities are
put them in your head before you pick up
the phone why the reason why
is because of persistence the reason why
is because i want you to have a good day
do you know what makes for a bad day
what makes for a bad day
is
snoozing starting your day off late
starting your day off tired starting
your day off by mainlining everybody
else's news feed on social media and
looking at everybody else's life and and
saying to yourself oh my god they're on
vacation or gosh they look so great or
their friends are so fancy or my gosh
they've got some money you start off
your day looking at that
you're never gonna have a good day you
gotta start off your day by getting up
on time figuring out your priorities and
then getting to work on them do not pick
up your phone until you have done those
two things i think the single biggest
reason why people have bad days is
because they start them off by looking
around at everybody else and seeing what
they're doing instead of having the
focus and the discipline
to actually start your day off with you
in control and with your priorities
front and center so you want a bonus
round exercise every day that's right
get up on time figure out your
priorities and exercise you do those
three things you'll be kicking ass every
single day routine number six exercise
with marie forleo they work out
i work out
what
this is a big one there is a ton of
science that proves that exercise really
optimizes your brain your mood and your
ability to focus hence optimizing your
ability to get things done now if you
haven't read this book you have to get
it right now it's the best book on the
subject it's called spark by dr john
ratey and we'll put the links right
below this video so whenever i'm
coaching someone that has a hard time
focusing one of the first questions i
ask them is are you working out and 99.9
of the time the answer is no so in my
own personal experience i always strive
for 60 minutes but at minimum
30 minutes a day of just sweating my
buns off and i'll challenge you to do
the same thing because i know when i get
that done it really helps my brain focus
and i know it'll help you too routine
number seven use sticky notes with jay
shetty one of my favorite things that i
do now
is that i have this little post-it note
that i keep next to my bedside table
and on it it says
what are you grateful for
and that message starts my day with a
different thought studies have shown
that when you're present in gratitude
you can't be anywhere else so when
you're having a grateful thought you
can't have an anxious thought when
you're having a grateful thought you
can't have a negative thought and so
it's so powerful to start your day so
grab a post-it grab a sharpie and write
a question on it that you want to answer
first thing in the morning now you'll be
able to tell that i like post-its
because as i brush my teeth i have this
post-it and i got into the habit of this
when i lived this monk where i'd put it
in front of me
and on it it says i am awareness this is
one of my favorite affirmations to start
the day with i recommend this to clients
to people i'm working with because when
you start with that mindset
you disassociate and disconnect
with the thought of i am the body or i
am my mind and if you think about it we
always say my mind and my body and
spiritual teaching suggests that we are
actually awareness consciousness and so
that reminder at the beginning of the
day
sets me up to now look at my life as an
observer to look at interactions as an
observer to approach relationships from
that
slightly
distant view so that i can actually
approach them with the love compassion
the empathy that naturally comes from
the consciousness post-its are great
different colors are great go crazy and
use post-its anywhere in your home to
remind you of powerful mindset [ __ ]
routine number eight wake up right with
saturday physiologically
one important aspect of you
is your heart
the pumping station
for your blood circulation which pumps
life
across the
body this one thing doesn't happen
nothing happens
this starts from left side
so we told you you know in india they
have told you when you wake up you must
roll to your right side and get up are
they
left side if you roll and get up bad
things will happen to you did they tell
you
bad things are not about that
when you're in a certain state of
relaxation
when the body is enabled relaxation the
metabolic activity is low when you get
up there is a certain surge of activity
that's why they told you in india
all these things are built into your
life which you're throwing away the
whole science of living has been built
into your life they told you in the
morning before you wake up you must rub
your hands together and see like this
huh
not see like this you must place it upon
your ass
you do this
you will see god
it's not about seeing god
if you rub these two things together all
the nerve endings there's a heavy
concentration of nerve endings in your
ends
if you do this the system comes awake
immediately
you're feeling asleep you're feeling
sleepy just do this and see
everything comes awake
so morning before you move your body
you get it awake first and then place it
upon your ass
instantly a whole range of
nerves
connected with your eyes and the other
aspect of your senses come awake
before you move your body your body and
your brain should be active you
shouldn't get up dumb that's idea
understand
so you do that and then roll over to
your right and get up routine number
nine have a positive vision with guru
paul das each one of you watching this
video
opened two very special gifts this
morning
guess what
your eyes
i often say
last night was the last night for some
and we are blessed with another chance
to live a better life
and we can make the most out of our day
and thus out of our life if we begin our
day in a proper state of mind
here are the five things to dwell upon
as soon as you're up every single day
number one
begin your day with gratitude
don't just charge your phones
watches tablets or laptops the first
thing in the morning
charge yourself up as well with
positivity that will last you all day
and the most powerful of all positive
emotions that'll make you feel empowered
is gratitude
because it forces you to shift your
attention to your blessings than to your
problems which are anyways going to be
an integral part of all of our lives
second
resolve to have a positive vision
nobody including ourselves
is perfect
everybody has a good and a not so good
side to them and the tendency of the
mind
is to look at the not so good side
every morning
resolve that you'll try and look at the
positive side of people and neglect or
deal with
the dark side
because the more we focus on the
negative our mind becomes occupied with
others faults
ruining our work our day our peace our
joy and even our relationships
third
trust the broader plan
tell yourself that whatever is going to
happen today the apparent good
or the apparent bad
is exactly what i need at this point of
time in my life
nothing more
nothing less
have complete trust
that every incident that's going to
happen throughout the day
that which is beyond your control
is simply a small part of a much
larger picture that will unfold
eventually only for your good and your
well-being keep reminding yourself of
this as you're confronted with
challenging situations
through the day
number four
do the small things right
although folding your sheets or
converters may seem small they lead to a
very big attitude like the us navy
admiral william mcraven said
making your bed in the morning will
reinforce the fact that little things in
life
matter
if you can't do the little things right
you will never be able to do the big
things right and by chance you have a
miserable day you'll come back home to a
bed which you made
and a maid bed
gives you encouragement that tomorrow
will be better
and number five
decide to help someone
don't they say
everyone you meet is fighting a battle
that you know nothing about
be kind be helpful
invest the energy of empathy love and
kindness and people around you and
you'll receive the same back when you
need it the most
also try to have a spiritual practice in
your morning routine
a deeper connection which will
illuminate your inside
so you can brighten the outside and
routine number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is prepare
in advance with jocko willing
one thing that i
that's actually a pr like a really
practical thing that i did
that and that is i had
uh this is again this is just like a
real practical thing i had
two cots
right slept in a cot slept in one cot
slept in one cot the other caught was
all my gear
and it was just laid out gun body armor
you know everything was right there
and
when i
when i got dressed to go out
all that thing was empty
and so
never forgot anything
when i came back everything went right
back on the cop same spot same spot
everything squared away
so those that to me was and i figured
that out really quickly okay just gonna
i don't ever want to forget anything
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna put
everything that i need right here now
i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 percent chance from
30 something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
creating daily success routines is the
secret to getting everything that you
want everything that you want out of
life out of business your hopes your
dreams your ambitions everything that
you want lie on the other side of what
you are doing daily of your daily
success
habits and routines i think we let
ourselves down by default i think we
worry about other people's opinions by
default i think we play small every day
by default i think you should have
already accomplished a lot of the things
that are on your list but you're stuck
in procrastination mode because you are
playing small by default because you are
not consistent because you do not have
the habits on a daily basis to keep
going consistency consistency
consistency is the difference maker
number one is chart your start what you
do in the first 15 minutes of your day
matters chart your start have a plan of
action most people wake up like an
accident most people wake up they're
tired you pull out your phone you start
looking on your email and what are you
doing when you're looking at your email
or looking at social media you're
responding to other people's emergencies
you wake up you're tired and the first
thing you do is you start responding to
other people's emergencies i want you to
control the first part of your day chart
your start understand what it is that
makes you come alive understand what is
the action that helps you feel bold
creative unstoppable we've all had it
you've all had moments where you felt
bold courageous and unstoppable what led
to that reverse engineer yourself what
led to you feeling bold is it watching
the video is it reading the book is it
having a conversation is it doing a
meditation is it taking your dog out for
a walk is it cutting the grass like i
don't care there's no judgment i don't
care what the thing is that makes you
feel bold and courageous and unstoppable
i just want you to do it daily i want
you to start your day with intention
most people don't start their day with
intention and that makes the difference
between the people who achieve success
and the ones who don't and so chart your
start figure out the thing that makes
you come alive that makes you feel like
that big crazy idea of yours is actually
possible and put that into the first 15
minutes of every day
if you did the thing that made you feel
bold courageous and unstoppable in the
first 15 minutes of waking up every
single day
not every day will be amazing but i
guarantee you that your life will look
unrecognizable
from where you are right now
chart your start so when i wake up in
the morning
the first thing i do is i do a gratitude
exercise where i ask myself usually in
bed
what am i most grateful for today
and usually you know i'm grateful for my
health i'm grateful for my wife i'm
grateful for my children i'm grateful
for to be alive i'm grateful you know
for my family i'm grateful to to have
experiences do you do that eyes closed
yeah i do that eyes closed and while i
while i think about that i feel it
and so the feeling starts every day with
a great feeling
so i start every day with a great
feeling do you visualize some things you
like your children or do you talk to
yourself how do you do that yeah i have
an internal dialogue um i see images of
the things that i'm thinking about and
that just takes me two minutes just two
minutes when i wake up
and then
i go to exercise to take care of my body
how do i um usually one hour to an hour
and 15 minutes every day
and so i do
a variety of different things i hike i
bike i work on aerobics i work on
strength i work with weights i do
whatever it is i just do it to give my
body the physical exercise
then as soon as i finish my exercise in
my gym when i run a half an hour an hour
15 minutes at the most
so then in my gym i have uh two things i
have a vision board which is my dream
board for my
you are known for that yes so i have my
vision board for my my physique and my
body and my health
but then i also have in in my gym
something called an achieved board
okay so after i achieved some of the
things that i achieved best in the
future no achieved in the past yes so
past you have the past and the future
so
i have in my in my gym in my home gym i
have a
like a place where i sit and before i
start my meditation
i look at my vision board from the past
okay so i get connected to the different
things that i've been able to achieve
and i remember every day
when i set my mind and my focus
to achieving goals
i can achieve all of my goals but what i
also do is i reinforce most people focus
on what's not working this isn't going
well this didn't work i want to remind
myself every day
yeah of look how many things i was able
to accomplish
by being clear by being passionate by
using these rituals so before i go into
my meditation which is with my eyes
closed
i look at my achieved board i get
emotionally associated with it to remind
myself that when i set my mind to
achieve something
i can do it
and then i look across because i have a
mirror in the gym and i look across and
i say i love you just the way you are
and i said i accept you just the way you
are with all of your skills and passion
and faults and insecurities and doubts
and fears i accept you just the way you
are
and i smile
and then i close my eyes
and i do about a 15-minute meditation
wow
and
in my meditation sometimes i have
no thoughts where i'm just one with the
universe and everything
other times i'll just follow my thoughts
and i'll just pay attention be mindful
of where are they going this morning
where are they going today
so i'll follow my thoughts and i'll just
follow them
other times i'll follow a thought and
say release that one
and follow another thought and say
release that one so i'm teaching my
brain
that i'm in control of my brain what
i've said before is that regularity is
critical going to bed at the same time
waking up at the same time and certainly
using alarms can help you do that and i
use the word plural their alarms what i
mean is not to have multiple awakenings
in the morning i mean we should all set
a to bed alarm you know think about the
time that you need to go to bed to get
that eight hour sleep opportunity and
then set the alarm maybe sort of 15
minutes before and that's just the call
it's sort of like last orders at a bar
now is the time to sort of start
preparing to get ready for this sleep
event
you can also by the way just sort of
before sleep in the last hour you can
sort of get into your pajamas your
sleeping clothes brush your teeth flush
your teeth do all of those things that
end up taking away and sort of an
additional 15 minutes or 20 minutes get
those in ahead of time
but what about the snooze button though
unfortunately it's probably not a good
idea because there is some data that i
discuss in the book where if you look at
the cardiovascular response to an alarm
it's actually quite a stressful event
for your cardiovascular system we see a
spike in heart rate stress chemicals
increase
now it's fine to use an alarm just that
one time in the morning to wake you up
but you shouldn't really be hitting the
snooze button because then you are
repeatedly assaulting your
cardiovascular system and you may think
well you know i only hit it maybe sort
of three or four times you know how bad
is that well maybe for that one day it's
not bad but if you're doing that every
single day every week every month every
year every decade across a lifetime you
can imagine the type of additional
cardiovascular strain that that places
on people so use the alarm that's fine
but try to use it once and then get up
and have a good day most of you lose
control of your life in the first five
minutes after you wake up i talk about
it in my book and you begin to respond
all day long the first thing is this the
hardest thing you will do and the thing
that will change your life almost with
the greatest impact is to not check your
phone for the first 30 minutes you wake
up in the morning i'm telling you that
it might be the biggest game changer it
is the biggest game changer for me it
was so difficult because so what i did
is i i moved it away from where i sleep
but i'm just gonna say to you all you
think that's not a big deal i gotta
check it i'm telling you if you could go
30 minutes if you could start by going
10 minutes to begin your day something
where you do not check that sucker and
react and then what you say about the
gratitude thing that's profound for me
and it's a breakthrough for me when you
said it i'm always kind of what are the
big things i'm grateful for god i'm
grateful for my kids you reduce it down
to just something what's the smallest
thing you could be grateful for right i
love that because there's always a small
thing you could be grateful for you know
i'm grateful my i clipped my toenails
yesterday whatever it is right there's
something so i just want to validate how
powerful i think both those simple tools
the simplest things make the biggest
impacts in our lives is there any daily
disciplines that you have in your life
daily routines that you would attribute
to your success
uh
yeah i try to beat the sun up
uh i write my goals down every day
and i try to get i try to hit the gym
so i don't do it perfect every day sure
um some things throw me off and and um
you know unfortunately i have a i i
created a lifestyle where where some
things are taking care for me that that
that um
most people don't have that that option
you know somebody drives the kids to
school i don't have to do that that
would change everything
if i had to do that who knows maybe i
need to maybe i need to start driving
the kids to school it seems like a
complete waste of time to me but
i live two two minutes from my office
so when i bounce out of here i gotta go
do a live a live stream on real estate
but but uh
yeah that that's the first three things
if i can get that done in the morning
man i know i'm gonna have a good day
yeah pretty simple b to beat the sun up
make sure you write down your goals yeah
make sure you take care of yourself get
the blood flow and get the heart pumping
yeah and i goes down fresh a new unit
like in a new unit of time like i've
written down today like i had never
written them down before nice
yeah
that's um so so simple on the outside
but so many people won't do
so
i dare i dare everybody listening here
to try to do it for 30 days in a row see
if you can even make seven man what's
your morning routine
every morning without fail the first
thing i do is i run
without fail i haven't missed a day of
running since 2016. okay so i get up i
do that four days out of the week i go
to the gym and every single night
for five and a half years i stretch out
for at least two hours that was a killer
part of the book every
night
that is that's where i so when you go so
hard
mentally physically emotionally
spiritually you have to have time set
aside to quiet
and recover recovery is big the mind
especially the mind and the body
this is my time there's no phone calls
there's no emails
the world does not exist
because i have to get ready for tomorrow
yeah get the body opened up why because
as i i won't get you know two you
wouldn't break through you went deeper
it was awesome but your body's getting
tight yeah
you go hard tom a lot of people go hard
what happens is that stress yep it
starts to tighten up that psoas muscle
hip flexors so lower back you got back
problems all of a sudden you have no
idea why it's all tightness it's all
tightness man because you're you're
constantly charged and going hard if i
immediately when i wake up i can't check
my phone in fact i put it on airplane
mode and i move it i got that from
ariana huffington who's amazing and
she's like is your phone still by your
bed she goes airplane mode on the other
side of the room you know
um
so that and then i just know so many
people roll over and grab their phone
and to me that's like russian roulette
you put a bullet in the gun and you spin
it it's like what if the email says the
deal didn't happen numbers are down
life's not working out like
and immediately for me it's like you
open up and and this little box is gonna
dictate the first couple hours or maybe
the whole day by what you see so i just
i just won't look at my phone when i
first wake up
um so but when i first opened my eyes
this is all and i like doing things
quick for me because i want to get to
the gym because the only time of day
i'll go if i try to wait till the
afternoon it doesn't work for me so
as soon as i wake up i immediately try
to think of something i'm grateful for
which everybody knows that and thinks
about it but i've i play this game
myself on how far i can lower the bar
meaning
i i try to do a gratitude journal about
three years ago and after about five
weeks i ran out of stuff to say i'm like
i already wrote my kids and this and
life like what did i put in here like
and then i was like wow 150 000 people
die every single day you can google it
that's the number it's like some days i
wake up i'm just like i'm here awesome
and i let i feel that silly little thing
like i'm here or i'll be like oh my god
they feel
softer than they've ever felt and i'll
literally think to myself
these are really good like
what a third of the world sleeps on the
on a dirt floor
and i have it's in an amazing bed and
look at the view i have and that's
enough just because the way i do it is
i'm just just tweaking my brain enough
to be in a grateful place it doesn't
have to be this for me and you guys
might have better practices i'm not
talking about a half hour gratitude
meditation i just need one little thing
or i pick up a book if i'm reading one
of the books that you have on the shelf
i'll pick and i'll just pick three
sentences and read something empowering
and i'll get that state of mind for my
brain and then i think about
one win i had the day before because i
know as entrepreneurs as somebody
searching for success we never give
ourselves credit we never treat a friend
the way we treat ourselves it's like i
know i've had days i've gone till 10
o'clock at night go man i got nothing
done today what's the biggest lie like
we beat ourselves up we just we're like
these racehorses we wouldn't even treat
a racehorse that we owned as bad as we
treat ourselves right so
i wake up and i'll do a quick little
gratitude and i'll say what was one win
yesterday that i accomplished and i'm
like wow you didn't do that yesterday
and then i'll think of one win i want to
do that day like what i'm going to need
a million things done today but what's a
must today that would be a great win
and then for me then i immediately go
downstairs in my house and i drink i
felt like i fed my my mind and i want to
feed my body you know my morning routine
five years ago was i would get up and i
would look at my emails a couple of them
i wouldn't let them consume me because
i'm dyslexic and i know that when you
read it takes more of the brain to
utilize to read it so i would use it to
stimulate my brain right i'd get up i'd
read my goals like i've always done and
i would try to eat something healthy and
then i would get to the office because i
was like i can't work out too early
because number one there's a lot of
fires that i need to put out and i can't
do that um as i started to uh realize
what was going on i started doing these
interviews with people i started saying
all right may i need to change this
around so now it's totally different so
i'll get up i'll do my goals i'll still
do that small part of reading the the um
email but i will not look at social
media which i used to
and now i'll go work out because i used
to work out at night when i felt that my
emails weren't coming in that much and i
wanted to kind of get tired so i
arrested but
i start working out now early earlier in
the day and and i start also scheduling
time with my daughter with my family to
make sure that that is priority over
anything else and i also schedule any
kind of health things i need to do
doctors checkups physicals whatever the
case is
what that did was
i'm more productive because the
adrenaline running and i got to work and
i'm i'm i'm more active i didn't eat the
egg and cheese sandwich slowing me down
right and i need to chill out for a
little while i started doing my uh
spending more time with my family and
because i started to say i'm gonna make
a major appointment any kind of
appointment i can once a month for my
health i ended up finding out i had
stage two cancer
after reading after starting uh to find
out all you know all these people's
techniques because i looked further into
my health and i ended up finding out i
had stage two cancer and it didn't save
my life necessarily because i had
thyroid cancer which would still be a
challenge but i had a surgery and i got
the cancer removed i'm cancer-free and
um and it was because of me altering my
life uh with these small adjustments
sleep is huge you know a lot of people
are like yeah whatever i'll sleep when
i'm dead no no no no no sleep when
you're alive and your life will be much
better yes i think 50 cent said uh
sleep is for those who are broke
and i think when i was in my early
entrepreneurial days i used to like yeah
sleepers for those who are broke if you
want to like make money and build your
business you got to hustle and do
whatever it takes and then i was just
like wow i'm actually getting fat i'm
exhausted i'm really angry i'm yeah
there is there's a lot of links between
sleep and mental illness bro people who
don't sleep enough can suffer can
develop anxiety disorder and all these
things um so sleep is huge for me and i
like my mornings i like usually my
mornings to be i like like two or three
hours to like drink like some some
coffee philosophy i like to do some so i
like to do some exercise in the morning
just whatever like some push-ups and
pull-ups just kind of some quick get to
get out of the way um have my breakfast
do email and then usually after that
like around midday by one i like to
switch from from that kind of
caffeinated email workout thing and then
after that i like to switch it and go
into free free association creative mode
and that's like let's go see a film or
let's go for a hike right you know
something that it's about disconnection
so the morning is connect focus and then
afternoon is divergent thinking morning
is converging thinking afternoon is
divergent thinking i think that's a good
balance for me i think it's just
important to stay
grounded and remember that you're a
human being not a machine and it's
really important to wake up in the
morning and take a deep breath and look
around at the people that you love and
realize that that's really the most
important thing and it sounds corny and
cliche until you start to do it every
day and then i've found that my life is
so much more fulfilled because of that
what is your morning routine like what
do you do when you first get up in the
morning you know believe it or not i
still you know i read a physical paper
every single morning which one i read
the wall street journal every morning i
read the new york times online
and uh you know i still i'm very
particular about having my tea it's very
english you know i grew up in india so
having my tea and
i'm vegetarian so i need to get my
protein so i always have an omelette in
the morning with toast
tea
and read my paper so i do that every
morning what time do you wake up
6 30 to 7 so that's when i do it do you
exercise in the morning uh now later in
the day sometimes
you know if i get a chance but always in
the evening i wish i could do it in the
morning i'm not a
morning person so i need my time with my
paper and tea to wake up and kind of get
going i've touched on a couple of times
we've done over 300 shows and i've
talked about
being able to handle the wattage of this
abundance that you want to have are you
actually capable of handling that good
that you actually want to have yeah
right
and it takes a lot of inner work it
takes a lot of physical work you know
it's not just a mental or spiritual
thing but physically to be able to
handle all of that goodness and even i
know it sounds crazy but you could
probably speak on that a little bit too
yeah no not and some people
i've worked with a guy named uh master
and dr shaw he's probably one of the
biggest healers in the world you know
grand master from china and he's a
medical doctor he gave me these beads
and i i trace calligraphies for energy
and enlightenment every day to carry
that energy and when people go to his
workshops at the end the biggest comment
i always get is man i feel terrible
right i feel so bad because physically
they can't handle
like literally when you go to tony
robbins or other workshops if you ever
end it and you just think you're
exhausted but you actually physically
ache and people get sick sometimes yeah
it's because they can't physically
handle the elevation that quick you know
it's like not jogging and then running a
marathon right your body's going to be
really sore
it's not humanly impossible but you can
actually do that emotionally energy in
motion and i see it all the time that
people don't as john assaraf says they
don't do the appropriate inner size they
do the appropriate exercise but they're
not using the parts of their inner size
to make sure they're fit and ready for
what they're asking for yeah so what do
you recommend people do to do that
exercise absolutely meditate and every
day so one of the things that i teach is
the consistency of things i believe two
minutes of meditation every day is worth
more than an hour a week i can prove it
in sports golf's the easiest way i'll
tell anyone look golf 30 minutes a day
with the appropriate help 30 minutes a
day focusing in on a certain area of the
game by an end of the year you'll be a
much better golfer guarantee even if you
don't play one round of golf
whereas if you play six hours of golf
every week on a saturday which is twice
as much time as a half an hour every day
you could be worse a worse golfer same
thing's true about meditation and that's
because there's exponential power in
doing something every day it goes from
your cellular to your neural pathways
into your unconscious even the genetic
mistakes that are associated with
disease
depends on how you live your life and
very simple things like sleep
meditation and stress management
movement
yoga and pranayama now yoga and pranam
goes way beyond exercise because with
yoga and pranayam there's a particular
nerve in the body called the vagus nerve
it's the tenth nerve
and the word vegas is a latin word but
it's related to the english word
vagabond so this nerve comes from the
midbrain
it influences your facial expressions so
you can now do micro expressions and see
if a person is happy or not it
influences the
eye movements
it influences the tone of your voice are
you threatened are you stressed are you
friendly are you happy
it influences your heart rate activity
then it pierces the diaphragm
and it influences the activity of every
other
branch of the vagus nerve that goes to
all the organs in the body
so when i discovered this through yoga
teachers and masters
i realized that the yoga asanas you know
we say yoga asana
and people usually translate that in to
as postures
but actually the word asana means seat
as you know seat of awareness seat of
consciousness
so each yogasana is a particular seat of
consciousness
that stimulates a particular nerve that
is going to
organ in your body and the only
reason for that nerve is self-regulation
or healing or homeostasis
so when i discovered that i became
fanatic about yoga i haven't missed yoga
now for as long as i can remember that's
amazing wow not one day of yoga or
meditation
or
or pranayams building yourself begins
with intention
clarity you have to know who you want to
become
you can't just show up in the gym of the
mind and do random stuff anymore then
you can show up in the gym of the body
and do random stuff and think that
you're going to end up on the stage
competing for mr olympia
it doesn't work like that
you've got to have this clarity of focus
and the way that i always explain it to
people people come to me all the time
and they're like tom
i want to help people man
and i'm like that is rad that's coming
from such a beautiful place
but telling me that you want to help
somebody is like saying you want to win
a gold medal
in what
the olympics
yes fantastic summer or winter
summer great tennis are swimming
swimming
which event
backstroke the medley because until you
know exactly in what way you are trying
to serve people you don't know what
skills you need to acquire in order to
leave people in awe so that you may
become extraordinary
skills have utility learning how to swim
better makes you a faster swimmer
building certain muscles in your arms
and in your shoulders
all of the different things that go into
getting great at any sport all of those
things must be learned with calculation
they must be practiced and rehearsed
over and over and over you have to push
yourself long past the point of boredom
boredom kills more people in the pursuit
of success than any hater
will ever kill
boredom is the great killer of dreams
boredom
because people don't have the focus they
don't have the clarity of what they're
trying to achieve they've not built into
their life built into their life an
intoxication for what they're trying to
accomplish so mitochondria their job is
to stay alive and then their job is also
to kill off the weak so you got to
stress them enough to kill off the weak
and that process is is called apoptosis
if you don't do that you get cancer so
you want to you want to stress you want
to stress them but not too much so it's
brief periods of stress
so there's like ice ice is great jobs or
ice showers yeah just a cold shower in
the morning yeah not a whole cold shower
because cold showers suck let's face it
yeah yeah just take a hot shower at the
end turn on cold do it all at once and
just feel the pain for a minute those
little guys they're going to freak out
that makes them stronger they get
stronger and the weak ones die right and
then you burn more calories throughout
the day your brain is clearer and
inflammation goes down and here's the
interesting thing every time you have
inflammation it's because your
mitochondria aren't working very well so
if something makes you inflamed it's
because you damaged your battery system
in the body when things are working well
they they actually change the structure
of the water in your body it's called
exclusion zone water and no one knew
mitochondria could do this until a
couple years ago gerald pollock figured
this out and he talked about it at the
bulletproof conference
so all of a sudden
you're just telling these little guys
hey the world isn't always warm and soft
and fuzzy maybe you should just toughen
up a little bit
and then that toughness gets built into
your system and you carry it with you
for the rest of the day and so you're a
little leaner you're a little just just
more on point and it cost you nothing in
fact you saved a quarter cent on eating
hot water for that last one like it was
just a change in habit
[Music]
if you want to learn the habits of the
world's richest people check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there and the first thought
is thank you look how much more training
i have done by simply starting at four
most people don't start their day with
intention and that makes a difference
between the people who achieve